what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest crazy chapter in the
boruto manga i was blown away by the
feedback i got on the previous boruto
review
so here i am back at it again and things
just keep getting crazier and crazier
real quick if you do enjoy seeing boruto
chapter reviews on this channel and want
to keep them coming the best thing you
could do is smash that like button until
it's blue and share this video with any
cultured boruto fans you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future boruto videos
as you impatiently wait for the next
chapter review to drop
feel free to check out my naruto boruto
playlist link in the description
where you'll find videos about to chiha
uzumaki all hokage and more
now without further ado let's jump into
its spoilers and all
this chapter of boruto is called
prepared and we get a cover of ishiki
looking dangerous and classy at the same
time with his signature
black rods that he uses in battle as
you'll remember in the last chapter
ishiki appeared right in front of the
hidden leaf village
chasing after kawaki and naruto and
sasuke were preparing to fight him while
naruto told borton not to get involved
and now let's get back into the action
very realistically we have citizens
notice
this horned alien chilling while being
suspended in the sky
and they question what it is while
people are just strolling around
as if it was any other day there are
warnings that an emergency alert
has been issued and people are told to
evacuate in the meanwhile
ishiki starts using his biahugan as we
know most osutuki have the biaku god
and ishiki is no exception by the way a
video completely devoted to the
otsutsuki clan
all of their members and their powers is
out being edited right
now so be on the lookout for that one
soon another reason to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you don't miss
it when it drops
in the upcoming days but anyways ishiki
uses one of the byakugan's known powers
which gives the user
x-ray vision i cannot tell you how much
i enjoy seeing the byakugan being
relevant in the boruto manga
because i'm a big fan of it and it
deserves love just like the shoting gun
and renagon
ishiki has no trouble seeing through
walls but he still feels like he is
looking for a needle in a haystack
too many houses and too many people
there must be a more efficient way
on a side note imagine how upset jiraiya
must have been
not having a yakugan there is probably
no power that is more useful in the eyes
of a pervy sage
as ishiki is trying to figure out how
best to find kawaki
our japanese chess whiz shikamaru is
passing on the message that no one but
naruto and sasuke are to engage with
ishiki
since he's so powerful and things just
don't get more real and dangerous than
this
imagine only the hukagi and his rival
being able to even
engage an opponent in a village full of
countless talented ninja
enemies don't get much more op than this
especially in naruto boruto keeps trying
to talk to his dad but naruto is very
much wearing the father cap
and does not want his son to put himself
in harm's way he tells him for what
seems like the hundredth time
that he should evacuate with everyone
else and that he shouldn't even think of
trying to help him in sasuke i guess
naruto doesn't realize that this series
is called boruto now naruto leaves
telling sasuke he's going on ahead
in the meantime the village is in a
panic ishiki is no longer just peeping
through people's walls he's landed
and is questioning people about kawaki's
whereabouts and this is when we see why
the do not
engage orders are so important to follow
for all side characters
one ninja is like i'll be the guy to
stop the main villain in this arc and
throw some shuriken at him surprise
surprise though
it doesn't stop ishiki rather he uses
his op powers to send them flying back
at his ninja partner
right after that same partner was
telling him to stop because they do not
have permission to engage
and man he is so right because the next
moment he has shuriken in his face and
chest ishiki pretty much views everyone
here as ants
so it's unlikely that he'd go out of his
way to hurt them
unless they try to attack him or unless
it will help him find kawaki he's as
indifferent as one can get
when it comes to these guys i love how
he still has manners though
after he just shurikened a guy in the
face he apologizes and says he's in a
rush
so he needs an answer saying that he'll
attack a civilian next if they don't
help him out
when told that these ninja don't know
anything ishiki politely says that he
appreciates them not wasting time
and asks them to point him to someone
who would know i don't know why but i
enjoy it when a series has villains that
are clearly intelligent and polite
that's one reason i like someone like
self from dragon ball more than boo
when you add intelligence and manners to
an op villain you get a pretty winning
combination in my books
as naruto is rushing to intercept ishiki
we
jump back to shikamaru sasuke and the
rest sai lets everyone know that there
is an unused and top secret black ops
underground facility where they can hide
kawaki
shikamato despite the thing amado pulled
with his sons suggests that he come with
them since
ishiki will attack him if he sees him
since amado switch sides
and i like how shikamatu doesn't hold
anything against the motto
and is completely rational now about
protecting him he knows there's no
benefit to holding a grudge amato points
out what someone's probably thought
yo if ishiki has the piaco gone can't he
just see through the ground
slash walls and see kawaki but sai
assures us
that it is protected against such
abilities i'm interested in how it's
protected exactly but we don't get that
answer yet and we
like amado have to accept that this is
true shikamato apologizes to sasuke
because they are
always depending on naruto and him i
found sasuke's response to be
interesting he says
it can't be helped but also adds that
it's a bit of a heavy load this time
for adult sasukes often stoic character
to say this shows that he very much
recognizes how in trouble he and naruto
are against such a strong villain while
shikamaru wants to follow naruto's
advice and get boruto out of there so he
doesn't bother
and or distract the two real contenders
sasuke is like hold up a minute because
he wants to talk to boruto
and i really do appreciate this boruto
and sasuke dynamic
who would have thought that sasuke would
make such a great sensei for naruto's
son
we then jump to naruto meeting up with
ishiki ishiki the op
ototsuki is surprised that our hokage
even escaped his ceiling jutsu as they
get ready for another round
we jump back to sasuke and boruto and i
really like this conversation between
the two
sasuke straight up says naruto and
sasuke couldn't make a dent against
jigen last time
so borto was right it's not like they
got any massive upgrades since then
while ishiki did
so they are in the hottest of water then
sarada is interweaved into the story
since sasuke heard from her
about boruto's shaky transformation
against boro at this point momoshiki
took over his body
talked down to boro and then proceeded
to borrow chakra from naruto and launch
a massive rasangan
that finished the job with no problem he
could also levitate which was pretty
dope
boruto now knows that that strange
experience and massive power boost was
momoshiki otozuki
taking over his body burto himself
refers to it as
insane power and we all know that he
will in fact learn to harness this power
sooner or later
then the real kicker comes from sasuke
who points out that the karma has
already progressed quite far
so borto may be losing himself to
momoshiki already
porto then points out something pretty
significant he wasn't hesitating before
because he was scared to die
he was hesitating because he's worried
that his body will be taken over again
and he won't be able to stop himself if
this were the case
he might hurt his friends and loved ones
and that's what truly scares him so
props to boruto who's not hesitating to
do his duty
out of fear of dying but out of not
wanting to hurt others
however we all know he's gonna have to
get in the robot
all the same and join the battle
meanwhile ishkiyanart are talking and
man this does not look good for naruto
while ishiki finds it hard to believe
that boro failed
naruto is visibly sweating and says that
they have many great shinobi so ishiki
should probably go home
this is the most obvious of bluffs
though since for naruto he only expects
sasuke to join him
and boruto was able to beat boro not
just because he's an outstanding ninja
on the hidden leaf but because he had
ototsuki help which can't really be
relied upon here
or so naruto thinks my point is if i
were playing poker with naruto
right now and he gave me that face and
bluff i would definitely go all
in sweaty naruto and chill ishiki start
to battle as ishiki
is ready to destroy the entire village
and everyone in it until naruto produces
kawaki and naruto's own shinobi way
is obviously not gonna let that happen
ishiki proceeds to toy with naruto he
kicks him around
pops up next to him before he can react
and hits him again
these otozuki are no joke that much is
made terribly clear in boruto
the only thing that stops the one-sided
beat down is sasuke coming in
and trading places with ishiki ishiki
calls sasuke's renagon annoying which
i'm not gonna lie
is pretty high praise here naruto
definitely didn't manage to annoy him
during their brief fight
we actually have a villain here who
makes six paths sage mode naruto
look powerless and we should let how
crazy that is
fully sink in naruto even calls out
sasuke for not coming sooner but sasuke
had some preparation to do
hence the title prepared clearly what he
did to get prepared is going to be a big
deal in this
chapter naruto has no idea about boruto
and just thinks sasuke is saying he had
the jitters
and that that's not like sasuke but we
hopefully know better you can bet sasuke
made the most of his time
getting there ishiki's talk is amusing
as ever as he feels annoyed that they
don't give up
he reminds them how badly he beat them
last time and this time he has a huge
power boost
like us he's wondering how could they
possibly hope to compete against him
sasuke the strategic one tells naruto to
throw things at ishiki
and naruto does as he's told sensing
that sasuke has a plan as they throw
shrutiken at ishiki he dodges some and
uses his ability on others to shrink
them
however then sasuke throws his sword the
previous shuriken served as distractions
at this point he's trained ishiki to
expect that he can shrink their
projectiles
but he fails to shrink the sword why
because he can't shrink living things
and the sword is in fact
boruto in disguise berto has the
osutsuki tattoo on his face
suggesting that he is consciously
channeling osutuki power to combat
ishiki's own
otsutsuki power this cool calm and
collected opponent is actually surprised
and that's actually a big win right now
ishiki is even more annoyed than he was
by sasuke's renagon
and just as we're about to see how borto
is going to take advantage of their
newly won element of surprise
we flash back to his conversation with
mentor sasuke
sasuke's whole thing was making sure
that boruto can use the full power at
his disposal
so they actually have a chance against
ishiki so he promises to do
what naruto couldn't he promises to kill
boruto
as his teacher if he loses control and
starts trying to hurt his friends and
family
and that my friends is how you judge a
good teacher if he's willing to kill you
if you go rogue because of a parasitic
op alien dwelling inside you
in all seriousness though this is big
stuff borto is significantly
expected to contribute in a high caliber
fight where even naruto and sasuke have
no chance to further drive the
significance of this moment home
boruto asks to wear sasuke's scratched
headband
in a symbolic way this suggests that
sasuke is passing on his
responsibilities and duty to boruto ii
and yeah this definitely doesn't bode
well for sasuke in this upcoming battle
however sasuke does say that he wants
borto to return it in person suggesting
he may well do that even if it is a
prolonged return
which it probably will be now again they
are trying to drop
hints that sasuke may well die but i
still believe they are probably red
herrings
and that sasuke will be taken out of
commission for a while in some other way
along with naruto to give boruto a
chance to grow more
usually in shonen the father figure is
absent and this forces the protagonist
to grow up quicker
and to become stronger that's pretty
much what we can expect to happen
probably sooner rather than later to
boruto like a character on a hero's
journey he'll have to become
stronger conquer foes and earn the right
to return this headband to sasuke
and when he does you can bet he'll be a
different more evolved person
boruto then manages to use space-time
ninjutsu to teleport ishiki away from
the village by himself
a pretty hype ability that naruto
recognizes one that jigen used on him
borto is clearly beginning to master
that opi otusuki power
and this is definitely just the
beginning father naruto is upset but
sasuke doesn't have time for it he
pretty much reminds naruto that borto is
a ninja who knows what he's doing and
they gotta hurry and follow boruto
turns out boruto brought ishiki to a
very dragon ball-esque setting for the
fight
where they'll be able to go all out
without damaging the village and to boot
they're far from kawaki too ishiki is
surprised and concerned about how much
of momoshiki's power boruto can use now
a very hype-filled question
sasuke and naruto joined the party and
naruto is upset with boruto
but he's gonna have to get over it as
borto points out
now they can go all out and try to take
ishiki down
but it will no doubt be easier said than
done as borto himself well
knows ishiki pulls off an otutuki god
complex moment when he calls them
inferior creatures
saying that they'll regret getting in
his way soon enough this is very common
for the otozuki who are portrayed as
godlike and tend to view themselves that
way
momoshiki used the same phrase when he
took over boruto's body
so in a way this emphasizes that boruto
has access to an osutuki inside him a
quote-unquote superior creature and we
may well see an otozuki vs otsutsuki
battle before this is through the fact
remains
borto succeeded in getting to ishiki
ishiki is not sweating or anything but
he's upset
and the fact that they wiped off the
calm expression from his face is a good
start
they're in his head now and they've
shown that they are not
powerless and that they could make
ishiki follow their lead
rather than the other way around not bad
for some quote-unquote
inferior creatures as ishiki called them
and that is it for this chapter i'm
super hyped up
since we should get some quality
fighting moments in the next one as
everything's been set up so well here
as always let me know what you thought
of this chapter and what you expect to
happen in the next one
if you enjoy these videos and want to
keep the boruto reviews coming the best
you can do is smash that like button
until it's blue and share this video
with any cultured ninja
that you know if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell and select
all or you will miss future broad videos
as you impatiently wait for the next
chapter review to drop
feel free to check out my naruto slash
boruto playlist link in the description
where you'll find videos about to jihad
uzumaki all hokage and more
and feel free to suggest some naruto and
boruto videos you'd like me to make in
the comments
thanks again and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]
you